how many of you have trouble loading the
app to your go-to grocery store snap in
a photo while you're shopping in order
to get that digital deal well we all
know I have trouble with that well you
are not alone if you do two eight news
now on your side tonight with Waze you
can save at your local grocery store
without the tech help this idea coming
during our call and phone make where you
the viewer shared concerns that are
important to you
there are things you can do in the store
to save money Savvy Shopper Andrea
warrock says you don't need your
smartphone or access to a computer to
save money at the grocery store there
are many things you can do in the store
to save money first ask the store
manager are there any senior discount
days many grocery stores offer senior
discount days this could be one day of
the month or one day of the week where
you can get a deal like 10 to 20 percent
off your entire grocery bill shop on
that day next sign up for the grocery
stores free loyalty program you'll be
asked to give your phone number your
phone number is then your ticket to
saving money because you will be asked
to enter in your phone number at
checkout and this will give you
automatic savings like digital coupons
that are clipped right at checkout hold
on to those grocery receipts to check
out the grocery coupons printed on the
back and make sure to check out the
clearance section inside each store this
is an especially good way to save on
those Fresh Foods look for the manager
markdown on things like meat fish
poultry or dairy those that are nearing
their expiration date will be marked
down by up to 70 percent off if you
can't find any ask the store manager ask
the butcher ask anybody who works at the
store if they know if there's a special
section stick with store brands
especially when it comes to Pantry
Staples you'll save about 30 percent and
when it comes to produce she says Go
Frozen produce is Flash Frozen at its
peak ripeness so you get more nutrients
and a bigger bang for your buck
we did connect with Smith's which says
it's committed to keeping prices low
every day but says the hottest offers
are in-store advertised on the front
page of the ad so grab its weekly
circular there's also the buy five or
more you save a buck each promotion
which allows customers to mix and match
from a large variety of items throughout
the store